So the answer is that Bob can cheat.
And the reason that Bob can cheat--
well, remember this hash function is not encryption.
There are no secrets that go into it.
It's only providing this commitment to the input,
and so Bob can easily cheat in this case.
He can compute by himself the hash of zero, the hash of one,
check them, whether they equal m,
and then instead of guessing, he can pick whichever one did.
So, with this protocol Bob can always win.
I'm going to leave it as an open discussion problem
for you to figure out how to fix this protocol.
And there are definitely lots of different ways to do this.
I hope there will be some interesting discussion about it on the forums.